for more than a week Israeli forces have
kept Jericho locked down and its
residents at Bay as they search for
suspects in a drive-by shooting
on Saturday morning the Israeli military
thought that located who they were
looking for and raided a refugee camp on
Jericho's outskirts
a house was hit with an anti-tank
missile and those inside surrendered
according to the military
houses were targeted as if the residents
were criminals while they were asleep in
their houses civilians who have nothing
to do with the incident no one has been
allowed to move freely out of this town
of 37 000 people in the occupied West
Bank after shots were fired near an
illegal Israeli settlement in the area
no one was injured in that incident
it's unusual for so many people to be
locked down for this long but then these
are exceptional times in the occupied
West Bank so far 36 Palestinians have
been killed this year in confrontations
with the Israeli military and there are
far-right ministers in the Israeli
cabinet committed to expanding
settlements and making life much tougher
for Palestinians than it already is
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Ramallah